welcome back everybody with musicians
like Beyonce Drake and Selena all
collaborating with AFR beats artists the
aphr Beats genra is beginning to truly
dominate the US pop music scene our next
guest is known as the king of aphro
Beats he's had the longest charting
Nigerian song in billboard history no
big deal and the first Nigerian music
video to reach a 100 million views on
YouTube his new album is called Timeless
it's out now everybody please give a
warm welcome for David
[Music]
[Applause]
you look so cool thank you man you all
out here looking so cool in pink yes I
must I must say this I grew up watching
you and um yeah my sister my older
sister was the biggest Kelly Clark oh my
god well she has better taste than
you I'm just kid so I'm honored to be
here you know it's a dream come true you
know all the way from Africa to you know
be here with all you guys oh no thank
you thank you as well thank you for
coming okay so like I love this story
your dad was very upset with you that
you left school right cuz you wanted to
you wanted to produce you wanted to my
family I come from a big big family
that's really big on education like I'm
first generation Entertainer in my in my
whole line of blood blood line so you
know what I'm saying so were not excited
he was he was he was really adamant
about me finishing school one because I
hadn't made it yet too because you know
what I'm saying he he didn't mind me
doing music but he was really bent on me
you know finishing school he owns a
university yeah so you can he owns a
university and you didn't stay in
school so you so so you can imagine and
my mom's U my mom was a college
professor so oh my God
I think they I think they're also scared
cuz they want whatever you want your
kids to do you want them to be
successful in it and in our business
it's not that easy to be successful so
you know um we kind of made a deal where
I go to school like two weeks out of the
month and the other two weeks I can be
in the studio and then do what I want
how did that deal work out with the
classroom because you just so and then
the deal also um you know my dad is a
very successful man you know he's very
wealthy so I was like all right you
going to you going to give me some bread
for my music I love you so much you were
like you set me up I will do this so
that that was really the deal but the
thing is that my music was always good
you know what I'm saying and he knew
that so the more I was going away for
two weeks doing the music dropping
videos my music was getting bigger
bigger so it got to a point where I was
a distraction to the class so I'm like
yes I love it yes I've made it yeah like
I was distracting to the class I'm like
I don't even got to leave by myself
myself they they telling me to get out
you know what saying I love it you know
so after a while then I I kind of had to
do like a per time class type stuff yeah
and then I was getting too big and then
he got mad mad I'm talking about he see
a billboard of me doing a show the show
going gets cancelled before I even get
there oh my god he has that type of
power he has that type of power what a
powerful you know what I'm saying so he
got to a point where everybody was being
scared to book me you know what I'm
saying so I'm like you know what this is
a movie yeah no this is crazy your life
is a movie this is crazy so at that time
I had a song that was like and at this
time I had a song probably like was like
top 20 on the charts in Africa but then
the next song I made went number one
like the president congrat the president
yeah the president like rock answer the
president the president of the country
my song was his ringtone so like after
that I was after that you're like I am
not showing up for class so sorry bro So
eventually though you know I went back
and and I did finish cuzz I only had
like a year and a half left So
eventually yeah um I did finish those I
love that your dad though he's seen you
like being all successful on BBB is like
no I'm going to shut that down you you
made a deal you made you made a deal and
now he's the biggest fan I love that
biggest fan it was important that's
that's amazing it's supportive in a
chaotic way like so wait you you named
the album Timeless Timeless and then I
heard did you go in I've actually done
this before because your life kind of
changes and it Alters some of the songs
but I heard you went in and re recorded
some of the the music for it yeah yeah
definitely you know how it is like you
know how it is when you you sit on
something for so long you get tired and
then you just I kind of got in a
different space yeah um you know when
like the album was getting finished so I
told the label I was like yo can I get
like three four more months you know I
went back home to my key producers the
people I was working with in the hood
before I left to all the glitz and
glamour like I went back to the hood and
I I brought everybody together and we
all sat down down in under 3 months we
completed the album and it's my my
biggest biggest charting album till date
man
congratulations that's so awesome I love
the coming back to like the your crew
when you first were inspired and you
first were like there's nothing like
that high you know whenever you're first
getting started I love that of course
and you know with our music of course
there's a lot of like afro Fusion of
course we get inspired by people like
you people over here rappers r& by
everything R but with this record I
really wanted to take it back home and
it's being respected worldwide you know
what I'm saying that's just amazing yeah
oh my gosh everybody let's do a quick
commercial break David O's new album is
called Timeless it's out now it's
incredible you got to check it out you
can also join him at this um are we
African yet Festival in Atlanta on
November 18th we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home